all right we're on problem 113
113 on page 287. so they've drawn this
thing let me see if i could draw it
so it looks like they have a right
triangle in the center
so one side that's the other side and
then
the base
it's right triangle
and then they drew some squares on every
side of that triangle let me see if i
can
how well i can do that
it's one square
well i don't know i'm going to draw the
other square because i don't know how to
draw an angled one i'll have to just
draw the lines
the other square
and then the last one i'll just draw
some lines look something like this
comes off like that
that that and like that so that's what
they have and they call this a
this
b
c
d and they tell us that this is a right
angle they say in the figure above if
the area of triangular region d is four
so the area of triangular region d is
equal to four
what is the length of a side of square
region a
so we know the length of the side of
square region a
so all of these are
let's see all of these are well they
don't tell us that this and this our
square region just yet but they tell us
this is a square region
right so the length of this side if we
know the length of this side
and that side then we can figure out the
length of
of the hypotenuse of this right triangle
so that's all we need and let's see if
we call let's call this length right
here let's call this little b
little b and let's call this length
little c
so we already know that
little b if we know the area of this
triangle is four we know that little b
times little c
so height times base times one half
is equal to four
that also tells us that little b times
little c is equal to eight
i don't know what that does for us let's
read the statements statement number one
the area
of square region b is nine
so
b is equal to nine well that's useful
right if the area of this region and
it's a square is nine what's each of the
sides going to be
the side is going to be the square root
of that right little b is going to be
equal to 3
right if little b is equal to 3 then the
area of this is 3 times 3 we can do that
because it's a square which would be 9.
so if little b is 3 then what is c
well then we get that c
is equal to
was that eight over three
using this information
and we got that remember just based on
the fact that the area of this triangle
right here is four
right so little b
times a little c times one half would be
equal to four so if we know what little
b is and we know what little c is then
we can solve for let's call that little
a and little a is what what the whole
point was about what is the length of a
side of the square region a so we could
just solve for you know b squared plus c
squared is equal to a squared
right this squared plus this squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared and we
just solve for a and we'd be done so
statement one alone is sufficient and
this is really messy especially taking
an eight thirds squared and all that so
i'm not going to do it and it would be a
waste of time on the gmat anyway let's
look at statement number two
statement 2
the area of square region c is 64 over
9. so c is equal to 64 over 9. so this
is kind of very similar to the
information that gives the statement 1.
if the area of this is 64 over 9 and
this is a square region then the length
of each of its sides or in this case
little c
the length of little c is just going to
be the square root of that so little c
is going to be 8 over 3 which is exactly
what we figured out here and then we
could use this information that we got
from the problem statement that b
times c is going to be equal to eight
and we got that from the fact that the
area of this triangle is four
so we use that and we can figure out
that b so b
times eight thirds is equal to eight
and then you get b is equal to three and
then you apply this again so each and to
solve for a so each of the statements
one and two are each individually
sufficient to answer this question
next problem
if x is to be selected at random from
set t what is the probability that so
they want to say what is the probability
that 1 4
x
minus 5 is less than or equal to 0.
let's simplify this real fast that means
that what's the probability that 1 4 x
is less than 5
and that means what's the probability
let's multiply both sides by 4. i just
added 5 both sides here and let's
multiply both sides by 4 and we don't
have to change the inequality since it's
4 is a positive number so it's the same
thing as what's the probability that x
is less than 20.
and i like this a lot more because it's
just simple and it lets me my brain
grasp the problem better
and what are the statements they give us
statement one t is a set of eight
integers
t
has eight integers
has
eight integers that by itself doesn't
help me because i don't know
what those eight integers look like i
mean maybe me all eight could be larger
than 20.
in which case it would be impossible to
find one that's less than or equal to 20
or maybe all eight are less than 20 in
which case you would have 100 chance so
statement one by itself is fairly
useless
statement two
t is inclusive oh sorry
t is contained in the set of integers
from 1
to 25
t is contained in the set of integers
from 1 to 25
so that also doesn't help me so t
within
to 25 so they're essentially telling us
that every number in t is between this
range but if we just take statement 2
alone they're not telling us first of
all how many numbers are in t statement
1 tells us that but statement 2 tells us
and then even if we knew how many
numbers were in t we don't know where
they're distributed maybe all of the
numbers in t are less than 20. in which
case there's a hundred percent chance
that you'd select one that's less than
20. but maybe
maybe four of them are greater than 20
right maybe we have 21 22 23 24 and four
of them are less than 20
or maybe something in between so given
that you still don't know where t is
distributed relative to 20 so i say that
we still don't have enough information
even with both of these statements to
solve this problem next question
115. it takes the most confidence to to
choose that e to say that one cannot
solve this problem
115.
and i also i'm always second-guessing
myself i'm like well i'm gonna make sure
i haven't missed some pieces of
information no but i'm pretty confident
here all right 115
if sarah's age is exactly twice bill's
age so sarah
his age is twice bill's
what is sarah's age they want to know
sarah's age
s for sarah's age let me scroll down a
little bit
problem statement number one says
four years ago sarah's age was exactly
three times bill's age
so sarah's age four years ago so sarah
minus four s is sarah's age today so
sarah minus four
is exactly three times bills
was exactly three times bill's age so
was three times bill's age then so b
minus four right sarah's age four years
ago was three times bill's age four
years ago
fair enough so just with this and this
can i solve for s well sure i have two
linear equations and two unknowns
so i can solve for either variable and
to prove it to you i'll do it
although this once again is a waste of
time
from the point of view of the gmat
s is equal to three
b
minus eight
and then b
from there we get b is equal to s over
two so s
is equal to three right i just divide
two
into both sides
so three
s over two
minus eight
what can i do here so i have three one
and a half s i can subtract it from both
sides so i have minus
i'm doing it fast just to minus one half
s is equal to minus eight
and then multiply both sides by minus
two and you get sarah is 16 years old
and you're done but you didn't have to
do any of this that was all a waste of
time you just have to see that you had
two linear equations and two unknowns
which is enough to solve for either of
the variables
statement two tells us
eight years from now sarah's age will be
exactly 1.5 times bill's age so same
thing sarah's age eight years from now
is going to be equal to
one and a half times bill's age
eight years from now
same thing we have two linear equations
one that they gave in the problem
statement and one they gave in statement
two and two unknowns no reason why you
can't solve for both variables and you
might want to do it for yourself just as
an exercise but you do the same way you
did it right here with i always find
substitution to be the easiest
especially when one of the equations is
really easy to manipulate
next problem so each statement
individually is sufficient to solve this
problem
next problem
116.
oh i just realized i'm out of time i'll
do 116 in the next video see you soon